the views and opinions expressed on this
program are those of the guests
appearing on the program and do not
necessarily reflect the views and
opinions of eight news now or next our
media group
it had to happen quickly they did a
tremendous job doing that
right now on politics now nevada senator
jackie rosen talks to us about
afghanistan what she asked our country's
top generals and what she hopes happens
this week
politics got super polarized
hyper partisan and on capitol hill is
nevada seeing the rise of the
independent voter we look at why a
growing number of people are signing up
to vote as nonpartisan
one october is a lingering presence
it's four years since the deadliest mass
shooting in american history the new
effort by nevada democrats to get rid of
the bump stocks used in the one october
shooting
from 8 news now
this is politics now
[Music]
a government shutdown is averted for now
thanks for joining us here on politics
now i'm david charns
and i'm vanessa murphy john is off today
a temporary funding bill will keep the
government up and running until december
3rd the short-term bill includes funding
to resettle afghan refugees and deliver
disaster relief to states 15 republicans
including senate minority leader mitch
mcconnell voted in support of the bill
do our part
to avoid a shutdown this is the good
outcome
what i'm happy we are getting done
nevada's entire delegation voted for the
short-term bill attention now turns to a
debate over whether to raise the debt
ceiling if they remain deadlocked the
government could go into default
essentially making it unable to pay
bills and fighting among democrats
threatening to sink president biden's
domestic agenda and it's also facing
opposition from house republicans
the majority of overwhelming amount of
our members are going to vote no because
they don't view it as an infrastructure
bill there is a two trillion dollar gap
in just how much each side is willing to
spend and progressives will not support
this infrastructure bill on its own
saying it actually has negative effects
on climate now when it goes over to the
senate it also just seems doomed to fail
i talked with nevada democratic senator
jackie rosen about the bill and
afghanistan
first i asked her about her questions to
the top generals during a hearing this
week
what was the response you got and were
you satisfied with the answers that oh
well we know
you know more now than we did then and
you know we didn't necessarily think
there would be a terror attack you know
were you satisfied with the answers you
got
so let's be clear that the doha
agreement was made in the spring of 2020
by former president trump
and so i believe as was testified to
alluded to today by the uh generals and
the uh of course the defense secretary
that
american lives american men and women in
uniform and others may have been in
harm's way had we extended past the
august 31st deadline therefore we
quickly had to marshal all of our
resources uh to do that massive
evacuation like i said over 124 000
individuals that's still ongoing for
anyone that wants to
be evacuated to safety our office our
our offices all the senate offices i
would imagine across the country working
with department of state and others in
order to ensure that safe
passage up for anyone that remains and
so i think that it had to happen quickly
they did a tremendous job doing that
there are a lot of lessons to be learned
and a lot of takeaways and this is just
the first step in those hearings to get
to the bottom of that
the
infrastructure plan which obviously was
passed in
in your body
are you frustrated with what's happening
on the other side of the of the capitol
building and are you hopeful that this
will move forward in the days to come i
can tell you that i was part of the
infrastructure 22 that group of 22
senators that negotiated this terrific
bipartisan package the senate did their
job we passed it in a bipartisan fashion
and i'm hoping that this week the house
will do the same the american people
aren't counting on them
is there something in there that's
really important to southern nevada to
to keep us going i know there aren't a
lot of specifics in there saying hey you
know we're going to do this do that it's
a lot of you know broadband roads
airports but is there something you want
to see that with that money i was on the
airport and broadband infrastructure
subcommittees doing that negotiation so
let's talk about airports we know that
we'll take the airport southern nevada
right here mccarran airport now harry
reid international airport
we had over 50 million tourists come
through there i believe in 2019 of
course 2020 with covet numbers a little
bit different but we know that not just
for our airport but for airports across
this country it's critical that we allow
them to upgrade their technology for the
control tower those control towers keep
us all safe in the skies we need to be
sure we've learned in the pandemic that
we need reliable internet in every home
in america for telework for tele
education for telehealth i'm going to
talk about tourism again you want to
book that great nevada vacation
somewhere you might use the internet for
that what about all those small
businesses that still want to sell their
goods and services you need the internet
internet for that as well so we need to
be sure that we have robust reliable
internet all across our country nevada
of course really we have some real rural
communities they need that help and we
are going to get it to them
and of course we'll put that full
interview on eightnewsnow.com
once again nevada will be in the
national spotlight in the 2022 election
and the state is seeing a growing trend
of nonpartisan registrations reporter
kate houston went to unlv to talk to
people signing up to vote you want your
voice heard everyone really wants that
at the end students at unlv spent the
afternoon registering to vote i feel
like voting is like very important
especially if you want to make a change
in today's society so it's really nice
that they're here to help me get my
voice out there the university sponsored
many non-partisan registration booths
we've had a bit of buzz so we're hoping
for about maybe
150 200 folks to register through us
active voting numbers in clark county
show a growing nonpartisan base august
registration numbers show 499 thousand
are democrat 362 000 are nonpartisan and
352 000 are republican republican
national committee spokesperson keith
skipper says a large part of that is due
to automatic voter registration at the
dmv we want to make sure that we are
getting anyone that identifies with the
republican party or maybe doesn't know
what the republican party is to
understand what we're about the limited
government free enterprise liberty for
everyone there was not a
democrat-affiliated registration booth
on the unlv campus in a statement nevada
democratic victory says in part
democrats have and will be focused on
ensuring nevadans are registered to vote
and have access to the voting booth from
today through election day 2022 kate
houston live local now
so are all those people really
nonpartisan and does that mean
candidates will have to reach out more
to the middle john langler talked with
unlv political science assistant
professor danley about it
the amount of nonpartisan uh voters is
is quite and large in nevada right now
what does that say about where the
political parties stand right now in
nevada if there's so many people that
are sort of in the middle it would seem
to suggest maybe that they're not
there's not as much of a connection
what's going on in the bat as far as
party registration kind of matches
what's going nationwide as far as
long-term trends and changes in
partisanship where over the past say
like since 2000 right politics has
gotten super polarized um hyper partisan
and on capitol hill people are kind of
dissatisfied with that type of politics
so what you've seen is growing
dissatisfaction with the major parties
and you've seen an increased number of
people saying that they're independent
right and there's also increased support
in theory for a third party
um
but the thing to keep in mind is that a
lot of these independents are actually
closet partisans
right where they're you know so if you
nudge them you can ask all right what
party do you identify with they'll say
independent neither then you nudge him
and ask him well if you have to lean one
way which way would you lean and a lot
of these are actually they lean either
democrat or a republican and they vote a
lot like partisans even though people
say they're
nonpartisan
as you're suggesting they're really not
so it doesn't does it then pay off for a
candidate to
try and reach that middle if at the end
of the day
it doesn't it's not it's not as fertile
ground as they would think exactly right
so what the parties are going to try to
do is find
among those nonpartisan which ones are
the partisans that lean our way because
the true independence people that see
that you know that are actual true
independence that don't lean one way or
the other they're also the people that
are least likely to turn out and vote
and kind of one of the big changes that
we might see over the next four years
is with sisilax signing that bill where
we're switching over to a presidential
primary
that's going to give incentives for a
lot of these independent closet
partisans right who are right now
nonpartisan that's going to give them an
incentive to
to register with one of the major
parties if they want to be able to vote
in the parties in that primary the
presidential primary in 2024 they have
to register with that party to be able
to vote in the party's primary so i
think that's one sort of i guess
correction we're going to see like
movement we're going to see in terms of
these registration numbers going into
2024 is where we're going to see some
movement towards
the major parties actually the idea of a
growing base of nonpartisan voters in
nevada that
isn't unusual
like nevada purple essentially what
you'd say purple state
yeah and it's not unusual just
nationwide as well right because again
there is this growing trend of just more
people saying that they're independent
like nationwide right um whether it's so
it's not just specific to nevada but
there are like other specific little
things to nevada like for instance you
know we passed that um the automatic
voter registration
law that's that kicked in uh last year
so what that does is you know when
people do business at a dmv it rather
than an often systems opt-out systems
now people who might otherwise not
register to vote are getting registered
right so who are people that are not who
typically wouldn't get registered to
vote people that aren't that interested
in politics those will tend to be
non-partisan voters right so that's like
also one one change in the past year
year and a half that's kind of
contributed to this increase in
partisanship
um
so that's something that's more specific
to nevada
there are more registered nonpartisans
than there are republicans in clark
county there's a third party called in
american independent in nevada it's a
far right party but in theory it has a
lot of people registered for it because
they think they're signing up to
register as independent instead of with
them so there may be a few more among
those
why
why
we'll never know the why
not that it matters
but
he took something from us and i think
that's the part that hurts the most
this week marking four years since the
one october shooting here in las vegas
nevada democrat dina titus introducing a
bill in the house this week to ban bump
stocks now they use a guns recoil energy
to rapidly move the firearm back and
forth
bumping the trigger against the finger
and simulating fully automatic fire now
stephen paddock used them to speed up
his rate of fire four years ago allowing
him to kill 60 people and injure
hundreds more titus's plan would require
those bump stocks to be registered under
the national firearms act nevada senator
catherine cortez masto talked about the
lasting effects of one october on the
senate floor this week
one october is a lingering presence
one that can return in a rush at the
faintest reminder like the sound of
sirens or fireworks
and it was the deadliest mass shooting
in modern american history and
afterwards there was a big push to get
rid of those bump stocks but vanessa
that didn't happen four years ago that's
right the atf created a federal ban
however after several lawsuits by gun
manufacturers a federal court ruled in
march of this year that the way they did
it was unconstitutional
and must be put on hold congress never
passed one on their own but if they did
that would be a way around that ruling
so we'll see what happens
welcome back to politics now
top trump aide corey lewandowski under
fire this week after accusations of
sexual harassment at a high dollar las
vegas fundraiser lewandowski was removed
as chairman of the maga action political
action committee according to politico a
trump donor from idaho is accusing him
of sexually assaulting harassing and
stalking her during a fundraiser last
weekend at the westgate lewandowski's
local attorney david chesnov said he
wouldn't dignify those accusations with
a response former florida attorney
general pam bondi is replacing
lewandowski as the head of that maga
action-packed vanessa the nevada
republican party and las vegas mayor
carolyn goodman are hoping to get the
republican national convention to las
vegas the next convention will be in
2024 the committee sent a letter asking
goodman to submit a bid and she said she
would state party chairman michael
mcdonald is also on the selection
committee nevada almost hosted the 2020
rnc coming in second to charlotte mayor
goodman said she would also welcome the
democratic national convention if they
wanted to be in las vegas clark county
school district superintendent dr jesus
jarrah testifying to congress this week
about how our schools handled the
pandemic he also highlighted how federal
money helped us navigate through it
hector mejia has his testimony
this is the u.s house of representatives
virtual subcommittee on early childhood
elementary and secondary education
superintendent dr jesus jarrah told
lawmakers ccsd included stakeholders
when it came to designing a
back-to-school plan including our five
bargaining units representing 42 000
employees of the clark county school
district together we instituted a mass
mandate and social distancing protocol
however he said they quickly discovered
many students had no internet or cell
phones at home in a matter of weeks we
were able to deploy over
247 000 devices and provide internet
access to the students who probably
previously did not have it ccisd has 304
000 students more than 70 percent on
free or reduced lunches dr jarrah also
talked about the staff shortages we need
more substitute teachers bus drivers
cafeteria workers and custodians all of
these vacancies are putting instruction
extracurricular activities and
maintenance of our district assets at
risk hector mejia 8 news now
you're watching politics now
dozens of new laws kicked in on friday
which was the first of the month and
let's walk you through a couple of them
first let's talk about pot consumption
lounges we're talking about ab341 they
are officially legal though they won't
open one won't open until next year we
know of that ab101 means a vet can now
give your pet cbd products and then
ab158 gets rid of the prison sentence
for underage teens in possession of weed
or alcohol criminal justice reform also
a big topic this past session it is now
illegal for cops to have quotas for
traffic tickets or arrests law
enforcement agencies have to set up
early warning systems to catch bias or
problematic officers and then a separate
one requires officers use de-escalation
tactics that was sb 212 many of those
that we saw this past session also aimed
at racial divides in policing another
law banning hairstyle discrimination
ab157 allowing people to sue if somebody
calls the police on them solely on race
religion or nationality and then the
hate crime law now changed so someone
can be charged with it even if they are
the same race religion or nationality as
the victim ab3 27 by the way that
hairstyle discrimination law vanessa
thanks david across the country states
are passing their own abortion
restrictions the latest and most
controversial is the texas bill allowing
any citizen to sue for any abortion
after six weeks so will the supreme
court take up that case john langler
talked to our washington d.c
correspondent alexandra lamone about it
a lot going on not only on capitol hill
in washington but also over at the
supreme court alex simone joining us now
to talk about specifically abortion
there was a ruling from the supreme
court not long ago that obviously got a
lot of attention there is the issue in
texas the abortion case there is it
possible that these might get
fast-tracked and added back onto the
docket here's what happened in that case
the supreme court just decided not to
step in on an emergency basis
essentially because the case
the law was just barely going to take
effect it hasn't really worked its way
through the legal system to the supreme
court so it isn't that the supreme court
you know denied to hear it they just
decided not to step in on an emergency
basis but there is a possibility
according to a georgetown law professor
that i spoke to that this case could be
fast-tracked through the legal system
and end up on the supreme court docket
this term even though the court
obviously is already hearing the case
out of mississippi that bans abortion
after 15 weeks the texas case is just so
different
first of all because it kicks in at
about six weeks or whenever a heartbeat
can be detected so it's much earlier of
an abortion ban compared to the
mississippi case but also because
there's just such complex and unique
legal questions in that case because
it basically tasks ordinary citizens or
allows ordinary citizens
the power to enforce that law by suing
anyone that they think
provided help to a woman in getting an
abortion um they can sue for ten
thousand dollars and so the legality of
all of that um is quite complex and
quite different than most of the other
abortion laws that are working their way
up to the court so as far as uh whether
that could end up before the supreme
court this term it is definitely a
possibility well certainly the biden
administration and the justice
department sort of wants especially that
texas case fast track they have filed
their court paperwork uh they're working
on that right away but is there a
hesitancy does it seem like on by the
supreme court to to wade into these
very very complex and very controversial
subjects
uh it doesn't seem like it uh like i
said they are
taking that mississippi case that's
already on the docket scheduled to be
heard this term um there are also other
cases uh working their way up through
the courts for example there's a couple
of laws that
attempt to be an abortion solely on the
basis of a down syndrome diagnosis and
so those are also possibly cases that
could end up before the supreme court
that was alex lamont from washington dc
you're watching politics now
this weekend what to watch drawing the
lines the county commission is meeting
to talk about how redistricting will go
for them we'll watch their suggestions
and we are still waiting for the special
session to be called as well in las
vegas also hosting the national
immigrant integration conference it is
the largest immigration conference in
the country the immigration services
director and lots of politicians will be
there thanks so much for watching
politics now have a great night